israeli troops have swarmed the area
around hebron and nablus in search of
the three missing teenagers
over 200 palestinians have been arrested
so far
most of them members of hamas israeli
prime minister benjamin netanyahu says
hamas is responsible for the boy's
disappearance
but so far no one has claimed
responsibility
the palestinians are cooperating in the
search
the israeli army is coordinating its
moves with the palestinian security
authorities
both sides have an interest in locating
the children
and the coordination is working
the three israeli boys were last seen on
thursday at a busy intersection near
hebron
the largest city in the west bank
young israelis often use bus stops to
hitch rides into town
the crisis has exacerbated already tense
relations between israel and the new
palestinian unity government
made up of both hamas and fatah if the
missing teenagers are not found soon
there are fears that israel will respond
with a military offensive
that could destroy any hope of reviving
peace talks between the two sides